welcome to another episode of legendary
on this episode we sat down with ritual
also known as Ultraman rich is a 52
year-old vegan ultra endurance athlete a
full-time wellness and plant-based
nutrition advocate author public speaker
husband and a father of four his story
serves as an inspiration worldwide and a
testament of living a proactive life
joining as ritual shares his narrative
to inspire
so rich roll the ultra map who is the
troll
oh wow you're coming out of the gate huh
right right yeah who is rich role isn't
that the ultimate question who are you
yeah you know I'll probably go to my
grave trying to answer that question
most of all I'm a father and a husband
I'm an ultra endurance athlete I'm a
plant-based advocate and athlete I'm an
author I'm a podcast host I'm a public
speaker but ultimately if you ask me
like Who am I like who who is rich role
that's really the question that I've
devoted my life to trying to answer you
know I'm a spiritual being having a
human experience and everyday trying to
live and do a little bit better that's
amazing I read your book finding ultra
and to those who don't know your story
why don't you walk us back a little bit
to how Ultraman came came to be alive I
grew up in Washington DC an awkward shy
kind of insecure kid one of those kids
that kind of walked around feeling like
everybody else had a rule book for life
except for me and I was very kind of
isolated I difficulty making friends and
then I discovered the sport of swimming
at a relatively young age it was the
first thing that I actually had some
adroitness with that I had some natural
ability and and talent in and I kind of
threw myself into that sport and by the
time I was a senior in high school I was
one of the top swimmers in my area
Washington DC where I grew up got
recruited at colleges and my life was
looking pretty good I ended up getting
into every college I applied to I went
to Stanford
in the fall of 1985 and was somebody who
had a lot of promise in their life and
there was a lot of people invested in me
actualizing that potential and shortly
after I arrived at Stanford I discovered
something I enjoyed more than swimming
which was partying and alcohol and I
would say at first it worked it brought
me out of my shell it allowed me to
figure out how to be a social animal for
the first time in my life I felt comfort
in my own skin I could like go to
parties and talk to girls and I loved it
you know and it really I think it really
helped me at that time in my life but as
any alcoholic will tell you it works
until it doesn't and it didn't take very
long until alcohol and drugs started to
really denigrate the quality of my life
to the point where all of those
aspirations that I held for myself
became secondary or unimportant taking a
back seat to where's my next good time
and so after my freshman year in college
I never really swam fast again even
though I was on this incredible swim
team at Stanford we won NC two A's two
years in a row and I was swimming with
my heroes you know Olympic gold
medalists and world record holders but
honestly like I just I I lost my love
for it and just sort of went headfirst
into trying to you know develop this
inner party animal that I had and it
didn't happen overnight but you know it
wasn't long before I realized that I was
an alcoholic and I continued my career
as a professional alcoholic for many
years probably a decade I lived in New
York City where things really ticked up
a notch
I went to law school in upstate New York
then was a lawyer in San Francisco and
then down here in Los Angeles and
everything really came to a head when I
was 31 where I got two duis in a row
within months of each other with
ridiculously high blood alcohol content
levels i rear-ended an elderly woman and
injured her so my whole world just kind
of fell on top of me and that was
compounded by an engagement and a
wedding that went awry that's a two-hour
SOG I won't bore you with but all of
that brought me to my knees so by the
time I was 31 I realized like I needed
to do something about my life at the
very end of my drinking career I was
somebody who was sleeping on a bare
mattress on the floor of a crappy
apartment I was unemployable I was
alienated from my friends and my family
really very much alone it was not a
romantic picture of life I was not a
vision for you and finally I got to that
point where I was ready to raise my hand
and ask for help and I ended up in a
rehab in Oregon where I live
400 days which is a long time to be in a
treatment center and that was really my
first introduction to a new set of
principles and tools to guide my life it
saved my life
and it set me on a brand new trajectory
and in the wake of that experience my
life became predominantly about recovery
when I got out of treatment I was just
focused on trying to build the strongest
foundation for sobriety that I possibly
could
meanwhile I was practicing law I was
very unhappy in that regard but
determined to rebuild this life that you
know I had a vision for as a young
person that person who had held so much
promise and so I kind of threw myself
into that and became a workaholic and
transferred a lot of those addictive
tendencies that I have into my career
and so by the time I was 39 I had been
successful in that regard I had repaired
my life and my relationships I was on
the partnership track at a very
prestigious Los Angeles law firm I had
met my wife we were building a family we
built this home and so from the outside
looking in it looked like I had a pretty
great life like I had all this stuff I
had all the trappings of the American
Dream successful professional career as
a corporate attorney
you know Porsche in the driveway and
family and all the good stuff right but
I started to realize that none of these
things I mean I love my wife and my kids
but what I was seeking for myself
professionally was not making me happy I
was sort of had this percolating
existential crisis about what I was
doing with my life because my whole life
have been set up to kind of do what
you're supposed to do if you're a person
of means and education you know what do
you do you become a lawyer an investment
banker a doctor one of these things
right and I was very good at figuring
out the system and excelling in that
regard without ever once stopping to
ponder or consider hey like what is
unique to me what makes me happy what do
I want to express in this short life
like I was just on the program climbing
the ladder
my friend Rob Bell says you can spend
your whole life climbing the ladder only
to realize that the ladder is leaning up
against the wrong wall you know and
that's what I was doing so shortly
before I turn 40 this existential crisis
was really percolating to the surface
and that really ran into a health crisis
that I was having because during this
workaholism period this decade of trying
to rebuild my life I had not taken care
of myself physically I become a junk
food addict basically eating at
McDonald's and checking the box and
take-out food in the law firm so I
gained 50 pounds I was depressed I was
unenthusiastic about my life
classic couch potato kind of sliding in
the middle aged on a crash course with
lifestyle disease so I was never more
badly obese or anything like that I just
look like a guy who probably you know
works in a law firm too much and so
before I turn 40 these two things this
existential crisis and this poor health
situation that I was in kind of butted
up against each other when I worked late
one night and I came home my family was
asleep and I was making my way up to my
bedroom walking up this flight of stairs
behind you when I had to pause halfway
up the flight of stairs I was winded I
was out of breath I had tightness in my
chest you know I was sweat on my brow
and really like fear in my heart like I
thought I was on the verge of having a
heart attack and heart disease runs in
my family my grandfather I was gonna
take down a champion swimmer yeah and he
died very young of heart disease so my
mother would always say you got to watch
out for your heart you got to take care
of yourself and you know when you're
young you're like you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah and it was it was it all
became very real to me in that moment
and it was very similar to that day that
I decided I'm gonna get sober
like a very definitive precise moment in
time in which I had this overwhelming
sense of willingness to actually make a
change and because I had achieved
sobriety I knew the power of these
moments I knew if I could seize this
feeling that I have if I could bottle
this moment
and use that as a way to shift my
trajectory to translate it into some
specific tangible actions that I could
take that I had another shot at
reinventing myself once again and that's
what I did I said about really
reimagining and repairing my
relationship with food first and
foremost and that's what got me
interested in a plant-based diet and we
can talk about that and then ultimately
in the wake of repairing myself
physically through diet and nutrition
got interested in in athletics once
again yeah which is something I hadn't I
hadn't done since I had venison were in
college and I think to answer your
question I'm finally circling back the
question that you asked me what brought
you to Ultraman in a very short period
of time after this sort of staircase
episode this epiphany that I had I was
able to change everything about how I
was living my relationship with food was
different I lost the 50 pounds I felt
vital and happy for the first time and
as long as I could remember my
depression had faded and I was
enthusiastic about life and the
possibilities that had held and that got
me interested in human potential
specifically my own potential because if
I could make such a small change that it
had such a significant impact in my life
in a very compressed period of time what
other areas of my life am i overlooking
what am i blind to right now what kind
of you know what is the potential that
I'm sitting on top of right now that I'm
unaware of and that's what got me
interested in magnetized by ultra
endurance sports because in many ways
it's a beautiful amazing template to
test the outer limits of not just your
physical abilities but your mental
emotional and spiritual abilities as
well so being an entertainment lawyer is
successful you know having your career
set your family's doing well
everything's going great except for your
health at the time what was it like to
leave a job like this and you know
financial security and all that yeah it
was scary but I think the truth to
really honestly answer your question
it's a much more complicated nuanced
thing than just walking away from a big
salary if you if you google me and you
it's sort of that that's what the story
kind of looks like or that's the way
people kind of portray what happened but
in actuality I had I had been at a big
law firm and I realized after I had I
don't know a year and a half or so of
sobriety like I can't keep doing this
anymore
and I ended up resigning from that law
firm without any job I didn't know what
I was gonna do no plan whatsoever I
remember telling my boss at the time
like I don't feel right about getting
paid to do this job anymore because I'm
so burned out I just can't do it you're
not getting any value out of me and I
don't know what I'm gonna do
I'm not going across the street for more
money I don't know if I'll ever be a
lawyer again but I just know like I
can't keep showing up here and I walked
out at that zero plan like I had no idea
what I was going to do and that
definitely was the most terrifying thing
I've ever done with the possible
exception of going to rehab so yeah that
was very disorienting but I just knew
that it was what I had to do for myself
and I trusted that I would somehow be
guided to the next thing and what
happened was within a couple weeks my
phone started ringing with opportunities
to be a lawyer in a different way like a
client that I had worked at at my old
law firm said hey I know you left but
like I still need help on this case if
you want to come and do some work for me
and then a filmmaker friend of mine said
hey can you do this I want to option
this book can you do this deal so I kind
of just started practicing law as a solo
practitioner not because that was what I
desire to do or that was my plan but
that's what showed up and so for a
number of years after leaving big
corporate law firm life where I could
count on that check that salary check
coming every two weeks I just started
practicing on my own and I was alone for
a while and then I had partners for a
short period of time and then I was
alone again and I had one partner so it
had all these different iterations so
that by the time I was ready to change
my relationship with food and the
trajectory of my life I was working as a
lawyer with a partner but my heart
wasn't in it
and be and when I'm sure you know when
your heart's not in something and and
you're doing it in an entrepreneurial
way it's probably not gonna work out
right so it wasn't like I was making a
lot of money I was becoming more and
more removed from that career path and
although I was still technically
practicing law and doing it the money
started to be less and less and less
because I got interested in other things
and so I didn't actually completely walk
away from being a lawyer until the day
finding ultra came out that's when I let
my bar dues lapse and all of that but in
truth I was kind of sliding slowly out
of it all the time yeah and and that was
frightening in its own regard because I
had no prospect for how it was going to
earn a living or what that would look
like when I wrote finding ultra I got it
in advance but you know that it wasn't
enough to support a family of six and
you know we have a big overhead and all
of that so it was great but it wasn't
gonna be a sustainable career path going
forward and there was no template there
was no like oh well you should do it
like this person or that person
there was no model for for taking these
ideas that I care so much about this
passion for ultra endurance and
plant-based nutrition and my ability to
write and communicate like how do you
translate that into a career that's
gonna be able to provide for a family
and I just had to figure it out slowly
and there were a lot of lean times like
we almost lost the house I we had cars
repossessed like it was not easy it was
very much a Warrior's path and I was
tested beyond anything I've ever been
challenged by in my entire life many
times thinking I should just go get a
job at a law firm like I can't keep
doing this we have no money I don't know
how this is gonna work and it was Julie
who said the way the solution is by
moving forward with what you're doing
it's not to move backwards and be a
lawyer it's to trust and have faith that
what you're building will eventually
mature into something that can provide
for us you know money comes and money
goes but being true to yourself being
fully integrated this path toward
self-actualization
and your ability to communicate the
principles and the lessons and the
tenets of that is what you need to be
doing and if you trust and continue to
work hard somehow we're gonna figure
this out and if we have to lose the
house we lose the house that's fine
you know we're together we're in love
but you have to continue to walk forward
with fidelity to this path and it was
very difficult during the time that you
were going through these ups and downs
and you know getting close to losing the
house what kept you going what did you
have in place at the time because you
said he didn't have a plan you had an
idea of you want what you wanted to do
so what kept me going really was that
the response to finding ultra and some
of the other things that I was doing
whether it was a talk or a blog post was
connecting with people you know I first
became aware of that prior to fighting
ultra when CNN did a story on me and
they asked me to write a blog post for
cnn.com about my story which I did and
didn't think too much of and that post
was so popular that they moved it to the
home page of CNN cnn.com and it was like
the most view to read or emailed story
for like 48 hours straight there was
something about it that connected with
people and I ended up getting just an
influx of the emails I think I got like
400 emails in a couple days of people
sharing with me the intimate details of
their own struggles their own journey
like things that like they hadn't told
anyone they were confiding in me because
they were they related to the not
necessarily the facts of my experience
but the emotions of my experience and
and it was so moving and meaningful to
me because I was just doing this for
myself like I just wanted to feel better
I wanted to figure out what my path in
life was it never occurred to me that
this would be a career path because this
took place before finding ultra and all
that kind of stuff but I became so
acutely aware that there was a thirst
hunger a desire for meaningful stories
to help facilitate
other people's transformations and their
ability to like weather obstacles on
their own path towards greater
fulfillment and purpose and
self-actualization in their lives so
that was like the spirit that that
propelled me that kept me in the game
and along the way it was like you know I
had to check my ego at the door it was
very humbling and I think you know Julie
and I were brought to our knees in a
very material way in a spiritual way in
an emotional way our marriage was tested
I think the fact that we were brought to
our knees that we were so humbled allows
us to now carry ourselves and
communicate with a frequency that is
truly authentic and that word authentic
has been co-opted and commercialized so
much that it's been bled of all of its
real meaning but the truth is at its
core there is something to that
authenticity because it was really hard
to get to where we are now but I don't
think that we would be able to be doing
what we're doing now had we not endured
that what Julie calls divine moment for
ourselves so along the way it was like I
would do anything that I I could you
know to make money if I had to you know
go and do a law job or if somebody would
pay me you know almost nothing or I
would I would go and do speaking
engagements for free all the time like
anything to get the message out maybe
I'll meet somebody maybe this will
happen you know the opportunity to write
the book came along I realized that that
was a huge moment for me
and then even in the success of finding
ultra coming out you know sort of
thinking okay it's out there the reviews
are good people are enjoying this book
like waiting for the phone to ring
because part of the message of finding
ultra and and what I've experienced in
my own life is that if your heart is
true and you you trudge this road with
faith and determination and hard work
and a sense of purity in your purpose
that the universe will conspire to
support you I've experienced that in my
life I've seen it manifest in many other
people's lives and so here I was with
fullness of
are going okay universe I'm ready for
you to conspire it and support me yeah
and it wasn't coming and I had this kind
of a moment of thinking maybe I'm just
full of [ __ ] maybe everything I wrote in
this book is [ __ ]
because like we were suffering you know
and ultimately you know we got an
opportunity to go and work with somebody
in Hawaii and we moved our family and
lived there on Kauai for three months on
an organic farm and this guy paid us to
do a number of things and it was like
thank God you know and that's where I
started the podcast and I had no idea
that the podcast would become what it
has become but it was sort of just a
tuning your attention to the universe
trying to pay attention to what is
showing up and being grateful for that
walking forward with gratitude and
ultimately the universe did conspire to
support us it didn't happen on the time
frame that I would have liked and it
didn't show up in the manner that I
imagined but that edict has proven true
again in my life yeah so would you say
that doubt was the ultimate test of
faith during that time like did you face
a lot of I faced a lot of doubt you know
doubt was doubt doubt was a recurring
theme and in in my journey and I think
that that's okay to doubt is to be human
if you're not doubting yourself along
the way perhaps you're not extending
yourself far enough perhaps you're not
pushing yourself far enough because when
you extend yourself and you're out of
your comfort zone and the path forward
is unclear and the terrain is is is not
well-worn
it can be confusing and destabilizing
and that's what creates doubt you know
when I look back on my life it all looks
like it lined up perfectly like of
course I'm here because I did all these
things and it all makes sense but when
you're in the midst of it you don't it I
just I just did a podcast with the free
solo climber Alex Honnold who's the guy
who scaled El Capitan without any ropes
like he's unbelievable and he said
something like I'm probably gonna
butcher the quote but he said something
like when you're in the middle of it
when you're in the middle of like trying
to find
path you don't always know that you're
on a path right you don't you know if
you don't know what the next step is
because there's no example and you're
trying to figure it out on your own
then of course you're gonna have moments
of doubt you're gonna be tested right
but I think if you're not being tested
like I said you're not you're not
pushing yourself hard enough to be
tested means that doubt will be provoked
and it's it's not it's not about
avoiding doubt or avoiding fear it's how
you respond to those things
when those things crop up do you move
forward with conviction and purpose or
do you cower in fear and retreat mmm
right and there were many moments where
I thought it's time to retreat I can't
go any further I can't do this anymore
maybe if I was by myself living in a hut
I could do it but there's other people
in my life I have four kids I have you
know responsibilities and as a head of
household
it can be very emasculating to have this
vision for your life this sense of
purpose and when it's not coming
together and it's not working out and
other people are being you know are part
of this grand play and you feel like
you're not doing your job as a husband
and as a father it's it's a it's a
terrifying thing you know and I've
definitely endured that and I think
without my wife who who supported me the
entire time and kept telling me you know
keep moving forward I probably would
have retreated because I think most
partners would say enough of this
nonsense like you need to go make some
cash you know go get a job what are you
doing you're acting like a crazy person
and I could tell you there were a lot of
naysayers a lot of people thought Julie
and I were crazy a lot of people said to
either to our faces or behind our backs
like what are they doing like what I
don't understand he's so talented he's
so smart he has all these skills why is
he wasting it doing this kind of thing
and that plays on your psyche you know
if you allow it to so developing the the
awareness and the conviction and the
faith was really the work
and so for me it's an inside job
it's about your relationship with
yourself and how committed can you be to
this vision that you have for your life
let's talk about going into becoming
Ultraman and the Ironman challenge and
how he got into that was that a way for
you to cope with all this uncertainty or
was that a catalyst for you to become
who you are today
I think both you know when I first
decided I was gonna try to compete in
this Ultraman race and we should say for
you know people that are watching
Ultraman is a double Ironman distance
triathlon the world championship version
of which is held in Hawaii
every November it's it's a three-day
event in which you circumnavigate the
entire Big Island of Hawaii so the first
day is a 6.2 miles swim followed by a 90
mile bike the second day is 171 miles on
the bike and the third day is a 52 mile
run double marathon run it's absolutely
bananas insane it's only 35 competitors
they keep it very small there's no media
there's no press there's no prize money
there's no attention it's very
old-school and in many ways what
attracted me to it was that it was
almost like more than an athletic event
it was like this spiritual Odyssey this
this this adventure that will take you
on this journey at the end of which you
will be transformed in some way and
spiritually mentally emotionally and
physically and I was attracted to it
because I was because I was starting to
integrate into my body as a result of
this change to eating plant-based and I
was feeling really good and and I wanted
I wanted a physical challenge I that was
so much a part of my life growing up as
a kid was something I loved I mean I
then fell out of love with it and I
realized when I started to think like
what makes me happy what do I want to do
it was very simple things it was like I
love jumping in a swimming pool I love
the feeling of the Sun hitting my
shoulder you know
on a trail run at dawn like those are
the things that make me happy and I just
made this very conscious decision that I
was going to start doing things that
made me happy because my career wasn't
making me happy and I was so tired of
trying to jam this square peg into a
round hole that I kind of almost gave up
and said I'm just gonna be Who I am
and that doesn't mean that it's a career
path but I'm still gonna find a way to
bring expression to this into my life
and then one thing led to another and
then this is what I wanted to explore I
felt like this was a great template to
test the outer limits of my potential as
an athlete something that I had not
realized that the swimmer at Stanford
because of my alcoholism so there was a
bit of unfinished business but I also
saw it as a like a crucible for personal
growth
I had these questions about what I
wanted to do with myself Who am I what
is my purpose and there's something
about the ultra-endurance world when
you're doing these events you become so
depleted you are tested so
comprehensively that you're really
forced to confront yourself in a very
real way all the denial strips away and
you're faced with who you really are and
that was what I sought through that
experience and the experiences that
followed and that's what I got so I feel
like it gave me a North Star and an
anchor and a sense of direction now how
that translates into like the career
that I have today is very intangible and
it's a whole other conversation but
that's what lured me to it and
ultimately it delivered on its promise
yeah it was really an internal and
internal Drive I just I became acutely
aware of how unhappy I was and then I
had a choice and if I wanted to be happy
that that journey would have to begin
with me making some difficult decisions
about how I was spending my time and
energy and it always reminds me of this
quote by Henry David Thoreau he said the
mass of men lead lives of quiet
desperation and what is considered
resignation is confirmed desperation
now he said that in whenever it was 1880
or I I don't remember exactly when leads
to grass came out but I think it's very
apropos to what is happening right now I
think we're in a cultural crisis a
spiritual crisis where a lot of people
perhaps even the majority of people are
stuck in lives and careers that they
find unfulfilled
robotic aliy reacting to the world
around us we're responding to social and
cultural expectations and pressures and
we're not living our lives purposefully
or mindfully and there's so much energy
into maintaining that system that to
step outside of it and question it is to
become a pariah and also to be
potentially you know ostracized by
family and friends and it takes a lot of
courage you know and so out of
desperation and pain I was able to step
outside of that and pursue a new way and
my whole message now and kind of why I
do what I do is to help people
understand that they too have a choice
that that what I was able to do and
accomplish is my own unique personal
journey but it is it is an allegory for
I think the hero's journey that we all
have locked inside ourselves to live or
live our lives in a more mindful
purposeful way not everyone wants to be
an ultra endurance athlete or go and do
ultraman I get that that's my version of
this story but I think everybody has
some passion or some unique creative
expression inside of them that is
probably locked down deep perhaps even
all the way down into their unconscious
mind that if they could find a way to
give that birth it would gird their
lives with a little bit more meaning and
a little bit more direction and a little
bit
more happiness speaking of meaning what
is your definition of success I think
success is the freedom to have domain
over your time and your energy and your
resources and to make choices that are
in alignment with how you want to live
your life success isn't a financial
number I know we live in Los Angeles I
know a lot of rich people that are very
unhappy there are prisoners of their
careers and their their account balances
real success is the freedom to have
choice and dominion over how you spend
your time
so why veganism why plant-based well it
began really with just trying to find a
way to eat that agreed with me that
allowed me to feel good throughout the
day without all kinds of energy lulls
and without crazy food cravings and I
tried a bunch of diets and honestly I
didn't want to become plant-based it
seemed really extreme and like some kind
of crazy deprivation protocol but when I
finally had explored every other option
except for going plant-based I did it on
a last resort almost to prove that it
wouldn't work
and within seven to ten days of eating
nothing but plants nothing without a
mother nothing with a face just whole
plant-based foods close to their natural
state it had a huge impact on how I felt
it just really revitalized me in a very
rapid period of time so my initial
impetus and the reason that I got into
it was really just personal like I was
tired of being fat and tired and lazy I
didn't want to have a gut you know I
didn't I didn't want to look older than
I was at the time and now I've been
plant-based for over 11 years and my
relationship with food continues to
evolve but I've never been more
enthusiastic about being a vegan
plant-based individual and athlete
because I think that it is a lifestyle
that checks a couple very important
boxes for me
we talked about this sort of malaise of
just dissatisfaction that that is kind
of happening culturally right now while
simultaneously despite the fact that
we're an incredibly prosperous country
we've never been more sick as a society
right one out of every three people will
die of a heart attack
that's insane when you think about it by
2030 50 percent of Americans are gonna
be diabetic or pre-diabetic obesity
rates are through the roof I think 70
percent of people are overweight or
obese childhood obesity rates on the
rise so we have a gigantic healthcare
crisis on our hands and this epidemic of
chronic lifestyle illness is not only
affecting our the health of ourselves
we're also exporting it across the world
and it's costing us trillions of dollars
it's bankrupting our economy so what is
going on we need to reframe our
relationship with food and the truth of
the matter is when you go plant-based it
is the one dietary protocol that's shown
to not only prevent heart disease but
actually reverse people that have heart
disease it is the antidote to type 2
diabetes people who have type 2 diabetes
they go plant-based they reverse their
conditions it's a way to maintain your
optimal body weight and then even
perhaps the larger issue at hand is the
environmental implications of the food
choices that we make animal agriculture
is devastating our environment at an
almost unfathomable rate every second
one to two football-field-sized parcels
of land are cleared in the Amazonian
rainforest to raise crops to feed cattle
every second every second it's insane
and I think the stat is something like
forty five percent of all arable land
right now is used for either cattle
grazing or to raise crops to feed these
cattle it's an unbelievably inefficient
system that is creating waste so profuse
it's creating algal blooms and are in
our oceans it's polluting our water
table it's creating the biggest mass
species extinction event
you know basically the history of
mankind in terms of it being man-made
and created the the carbon emissions
from animal agriculture are are more
profound than all the transportation
sector combined the amount of land and
water and resources that go into raising
these animals for food it doesn't make
sense
it's insane and when you go plant-based
you opt out of that system altogether
not only are you doing that you're also
sparing all these animals lives these
animals that are treated horribly that
are slaughtered that are tortured and
all the like so for me it is it's a it's
a beautiful ethical way to live it's not
it's not like a zero impact lifestyle
it's just a way to sort of walk the
planet a little bit lighter in a way
that's more environmentally conscious
and kind that's a that sort of crafts a
more ethical perspective on on how we
treat our fellow animal friends on the
planet and it also is a very healthy way
to live so for me it's like do the math
like it seemed it's an incredible
lifestyle and if I can go out and and
you know kick ass and Ultraman and do
epic fight I did five Iron Man's on five
wine Islands in under a week you can be
an athlete at the highest level and
still eat this way there's no protein
deficiency issues there's I mean we
could talk for it say you don't get all
the nutrients you need it's it's it's
it's really a fallacy it really is a
fallacy I've never met a doctor who said
I'm treating patients for protein
deficiencies it's just like every food
that you eat has protein in it when you
talk about protein what you're really
talking about is amino acids and
specifically these nine amino acids that
are called the essential amino acids
those are the amino acids that our
bodies cannot synthesize on our own we
have to get them from our food and
people are under the misapprehension
that the only way to get them is through
animal products but the animals get them
through eating plants so I'm just eating
lower on the food chain but doing it 11
years I'm able to I'm 51 years old right
now I go out and I push my body as hard
as anybody out there
I continue to develop as an athlete get
stronger get faster I've never had an
issue building lean muscle mass I hit my
athletic peak at like age 45 so you know
I stand in contradiction to this idea
that you cannot be healthy or thrive or
be at your athletic peak unless you're
eating animal products I think it is a
great fallacy it's a gigantic lie it's a
red herring issue and I invite anybody
who's watching this or listening to try
it for 30 days see how you feel don't
take my word for it do your own
experimentation on yourself
you and your wife Julie are starting a
movement in a way that you're pushing
for the plant-based diet you've
published multiple books and now she's
starting her own line of you can cheese
you can GE cheese products yeah so Julie
came out with a book last year called
this cheese is nuts where she spent two
years perfecting the art of making
non-dairy plant-based cheese's I'm an
artist and a singer and and I just come
into whatever I create in life it
doesn't really matter the medium it's
all the one creative force and really in
cheese because I just went into this
like a child trying things and making
stuff up I knew that I would create some
recipes that were pretty good but I
never imagined that I would create
recipes with this level of taste texture
it's it's shocking that there's no dairy
in these products Julie has really
cracked the code on this like she's come
up with some unbelievable recipes you
try have to say they're like insane yeah
it's like you're like what how is this
how does this not have darian it's
unbelievable so that is a universal
response to everybody who has tasted her
cheese's all the recipes of which you
could find in her book but there's a lot
of people that are just not gonna make
vegan cheese at home so she's like I'm
gonna make a line so she's embarking on
the process of commercializing
some of these cheese products which i
think is really exciting and great and
you know what's interesting about that
is that
you know after our first cookbook came
out the plant power way and we were
thinking what's the next book that we
want to write or that Julie wants to
write there were a lot of people said oh
why don't you do a smoothie book or a
pizza but or something like that she's
like no I want to I want to figure out
how to do unbelievably amazing tasting
cheese because that is the one thing
when you meet people and I meet a lot of
people who I talk to about diet
nutrition they say I'd love to go
plant-based I tried it but like cheese I
just I can't give up cheese cheese is
very difficult to give up it was
difficult for me to give up I understand
that I'm sympathetic to that so we
wanted to basically address that problem
and solve it for them and I think Julie
has done that so it's pretty cool what
would you say is the key element a
successful relationship like that that
you enjoy they have well there's a lot
but I think one of the one of the things
that has been very helpful to us is to
understand that we're each sovereign
individuals I'm not here to complete her
she's not here to complete me I'm not
trying to change her and she's not
trying to change me we have our own
independent lives that and we respect
that and each other and then we can kind
of come together and like I said do this
dance but it's the opposite of when you
see Jerry Maguire and he's like you
complete me like you know what I mean
you your job is to complete yourself mmm
you need to invest in that inside job
that interior journey for yourself so
that you can be the best version of
yourself for your partner what's on the
horizon for ritual I know there's a new
book coming up yes so finding ultra came
out in 2012 but I just spent this past
year completely rewriting the book and
the new second edition revised edition
of that comes out in mid-march March
13th it hits bookstores it's a hundred
pages longer a new forward a brand-new
sixty page chapter that's very
prescriptive I kind of walk people
through all the tools that I relied on
to transform my life in the hopes that
you know that
benefit to somebody who's struggling
there's a recipe section I put in this
cleanse that I did there was a lot of
people who were interested in that and I
just rewrote a lot of the pros that I
wasn't happy with so I'm really excited
about that being out and then Julianne I
have a brand new cookbook called the
plant power way italia that comes out
April 24th and that is inspired by these
retreats that Julie and I do in the
Tuscan countryside where we take groups
of people through a week-long seven-day
transformative excursion and adventure
that has a lot to do with plant-based
nutrition cuisine but also meditation
mindfulness athleticism you know
spiritual development relationships and
the like and the experience of taking
these groups through these experiences
in the Italian countryside has kind of
inspired Julie's acumen in the kitchen
she's developed 125 new plant-based
recipes that are Italian which is pretty
exciting so we're excited about that
yeah so finally what's a message you'd
like to leave the viewers with the first
question that you asked me I would put
that on the audience like who are you
you know who are you like I want people
to really think about that and wrestle
with that and not just say oh I'm a I'm
an entrepreneur I'm an athlete I'm a I'm
a youtube or whatever it is
no that's not the answer who are you who
are what makes you tick what do you care
about what is your unique blueprint what
is your what is it that that that you
can express and manifest in the world
that is uniquely you you know and I
think if you a tune your focus to that
that will unlock doors that will provide
the path forward for what you should do
with your life
do you think it comes with experience
and time or do you think anyone can do
it at any certain point of their life I
think it's helpful if you're in pain
because pain is a great motivator so if
you're suffering and you're unhappy I
would say rather than try to make
yourself feel better
leverage that pain point to do that work
and self improve but you don't have to
be in pain anybody can do make a choice
make a decision it's harder to make
those decisions when things are going
well or you've kind of set up your life
with a lot of distractions but I think
if you can develop the wherewithal the
spine the devotion the dedication the
intention to do that kind of work that
is the path of the master rich you're
officially a legend but now a legendary
legend legendary so thanks my pleasure
thank you so much talk to you appreciate
it thank you so much
[Music]
you